hey we're back in this video we're gonna
talk about all the possible reasons for
not being able to sleep then I'm gonna
put links down below of what you need to
do about it okay so let's go ahead and
just kind of take it from the beginning
let's say for example you like coffee
and you're drinking too much coffee
which has caffeine and that's a big
reason why you're not gonna be able to
sleep at night but also don't forget
about tea there's caffeine and tea and
there's also stimulants in chocolate too
so if you're doing chocolate too much of
it that could keep you up now when you
exercise there's always an optimum
amount of exercise so if you're
overtraining and you find that your
pulse rate is just way too high when
you're going to sleep at night and you
can actually hear the pulse rate on your
pillow and your inner ear then we know
that you're overtraining and that reason
can be easily corrected by just kind of
going a light with your workouts maybe
doing long walks I highly recommend that
if you have a sleeping problem that you
do long walks in the evening impossible
it's low stress a lot of oxygen it's
good for the adrenals especially if
you're on the computer all day long like
I am so I have to continually exercise
and walk and just get out of the house
because I'm sit in front of that darn
computer all day long and that could
actually interfere with your sleep as
well now there's two other situations
that occur with a high pulse right
number one is if your pH is too acidic
let's say for example you're consuming
outside of vinegar or kombucha tea in
larger amounts later at night that can
shift your pH to being too acid and
raise your pulse rate and prevent
sleeping what happened to me so I can
tell you from firsthand experience now
the other reason is the potassium
deficiency potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it calms the nervous system
down
it keeps the pulse rate down and when
you're low in potassium your pulse rate
will go up or it can stem from consuming
too many refined carbohydrates that pull
potassium out of your body a good
electrolyte with a lot of potassium will
help keep the pulse rate down as well as
the blood pressure okay so the next
thing is carbohydrates if you're
consuming too many refined carbs or
sugar and the early part of the
let's say you're you're eating a pancake
breakfast or orange juice whatever
what'll happen in the evening you're
gonna be crave carbs and you're probably
gonna give in to that and that alone can
keep you from sleeping at night now
let's talk about the key minerals for
sleeping it's basically potassium and
magnesium we need a lot of potassium and
a good amount of magnesium well you get
these minerals from leafy greens from
salad from vegetables so I recommend
that you consume a lot of those unless
you have the inability to digest the
salad but if you can digest it I would
consume at least seven cups even more
than that maybe up to ten cups that will
give you the potassium and magnesium the
days that I consume a little more salad
are the days that I get a little bit
better sleep in meat and fish and eggs
all those proteins are high in
phosphorus phosphorus is an accelerator
of the nervous system so if you're
consuming too much protein not enough
vegetable that could be a reason why
you're not sleeping now there's one more
point about eating too late it's not a
problem unless your meal is too heavy in
the fats if you're consuming too much
fat at night because you're doing a
ketogenic diet and it just happens to be
that you know your second meal is later
that can actually irritate the
gallbladder affect your digestion and
prevent you from sleeping comfortably so
I would recommend consuming more of your
fat earlier in the day now there's a
couple things that can actually prevent
you from going to sleep number one
watching the news before you go to bed
that is a very bad idea
you want to watch a comedy or just read
a book there's a thing called EMF
electromagnetic fields so if your cell
phone is next to your head or you have
some electrical device that's plugged in
you know people have like by their head
they have alarm clocks they have
different electrical devices those put
out a certain frequency called EMF and
that can interfere with your ability
sleep as well so make sure around your
head you don't have any electrical
devices you don't have a transformer
right next to your head that can create
a problem light so what happens is
darkness stimulates melatonin
tonin is the sleep hormone it's created
by the pineal gland so if your room is
really really light and you're watching
TV whatever that's gonna keep you up so
you want to turn the lights off have dim
lights and it's gonna help you go to
sleep breathing so I recommend if you're
laying down and you're going to sleep
and you can't sleep focus on your
breathing
if you can actually slow down your
inhalation to five seconds of an
inhalation and then five seconds of an
exhalation it'll actually calm down your
nervous system because when your body's
under stress you kind of breathe like
this it's like I'm exaggerating but the
exhalation is shorter than the
inhalation so you want to balance those
out and that can help you sleep I
recommend you also sleep on your right
side simply because the liver is on the
right side the hearts on the left side
usually on most people so if you're
sleeping on the right side the heart
will sit on the liver if you're sleeping
on the left side if your liver is fatty
it can kind of compress the heart and
just make it a little bit more
uncomfortable to go to sleep there's an
optimum time of sleep which is about
10:30 and this is based on the circadian
rhythms or waves hormone wave so if you
go past this time and let's say you stay
up past midnight you're gonna find
typically that it's harder to go to
sleep because you you miss this wave and
you have to wait another period of time
before your body can actually get into
the sleep so I recommend 10:30 is a
really good time to actually you know
maybe like quarter after 10:00 you're
trying to go to sleep and then really
shoot for 10:30 10:45 that seems to be a
good time to go to sleep if you have
excessive thinking at night and you're
you're just excessively just this is
going going going going vitamin b1 is
going to help you nutritional yeast is a
really good product for that sometimes
people are woken from muscle cramps that
is the potassium and magnesium problem
sometimes you need more sea salt and you
can also use pickle juice to help with
cramps if you if you don't happen to
have electrolyte powder or you haven't
had enough salad and it's like you need
to sleep just I'm sure you have some
pickle juice so you can actually drink
some of that
that will actually get rid of cramps
pretty fast now let's talk about
digestion if you have a condition called
SIBO which I'm going to put a link down
below which is small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth where you have too
much bacteria in the wrong place and you
add the fiber from the vegetables that's
gonna blow you so that's gonna keep you
up at night so what you have to do is
make sure that you can digest the salad
and if you can't you're gonna have to
handle that I put a link down below how
to do that also if you're getting gas or
disruption in your vows it could be the
consumption of sugar alcohols in some of
the foods like xylitol or a throat all
that you're not used to creating that
disruption it can also come from MCT oil
in some of the products that are so
called keto friendly but you got to get
used to it you got to take very small
amounts of that one thing that I take I
have a product called sleep aid I take
one before bed this is mainly for the
adrenals I also use the massage tool I
do that technique to pull stress out
because if the adrenal glands are
overactive it's gonna keep you from
resting so let's just talk about the
adrenal for a second the Drina gland you
have two of them they're sitting on top
of the kidneys right in here and they
kind of help regulate stress all day
long if you're going through stress the
goal is to extract that stress so you're
not trying to go to sleep on top of a
stressed-out body now one thing I always
recommend if you're trying to sleep and
you can't sleep scan your body and just
be aware of of what part of your body
won't turn off okay so it might be your
head for example it might be the chest
it might be your lower back and usually
there's either tension spasm in the
muscle or some type of old injury could
could keep the body just kind of revved
up and prevent your that air of your
body from relaxing so if you have a
muscle spasm whatever there are all
sorts of things you can do to extract
that stress and do stretching I put a
link down below it's in a stress webinar
that I did of how to do that you can use
this technique right here but one little
side note on that I've noticed
especially with people that when they go
to sleep like their head is not tired
it's just a wake all the time
that usually comes from an old head
injury that you had which is interesting
how it correlates so let's say for
example you were in an accident
something hits your head there's a
technique I'll put a link down below
that you can do to kind of release that
tension and it really does work so
that's just a little side note also if
you're in a fight with your spouse you
had some bad news that mental stress is
going to keep you up obviously you need
to confront that face that and handle
that before you try to you know go to
sleep and try to push it off it's just
going to prevent you from sleeping if
there's pain in the body or inflammation
or fibromyalgia that's a no-brainer I
put a link down below of all the
different ways to get rid of
inflammation the big one being
intermittent fasting so that's going to
be really important if you have
inflammation or a pain and there's other
techniques too they can do to get rid of
pain and tension in your body one of the
good indicators that of adrenal is that
waking up at 2 o'clock in the in the
morning 2 a.m. that's like classic
adrenal because at 2 o'clock you have
cortisol being the lowest point okay so
at 8 o'clock it's the highest point and
the adrenal hormone cortisol is a stress
hormone so if your course hall is too
high at the wrong time at 2 a.m. it's
gonna bump you out of sleep and I used
to have this problem big time I had
restless leg syndrome restless leg
syndrome is purely a vitamin b1
deficiency just need to take more be B
vitamins but specifically b1 and then
stop eating sugar that was my problem
long ago and I would have to just rub my
legs and like get up and start to get
this energy out of my my legs but 2:00
a.m. but also adrenal could be just you
can't get to sleep at night or you know
a half hour before the alarm clock goes
off you're just like you're awake so you
want to spend some time learning about
the adrenals and doing things to improve
it now if you were to athlete long ago
and used to workout hardcore but now you
don't what happens is that the
mitochondria the energy factories that
are involved in energy production are
developed a lot bigger than other people
so they store more and
so what happens is that you need to
continue to work out so that's gonna
actually drain off some of the energy so
if you're sitting all day and from your
computer you're not working out and you
just all this energy is sitting and
you're trying to go to bed with all this
excess energy it could be because you're
an athlete before and your mitochondria
are just designed to use and store and
use up energy so you need to use it up
by getting out there and doing some
workouts if the bladder is waking you
want there's several things situations
for that usually it's insulin resistance
insulin resistance is a pre-diabetic
situation and think about a diabetic
they they're thirsty a lot and they pee
excessive amounts well that is what it
is so how do you correct that put the
link down below you would do healthy
keto and in a minute fasting but let's
say for example you have an enlarged
prostate and that's keeping the bladder
from holding urine the best thing to do
is to avoid all dairy okay milk butter
cream cheese just avoid dairy for a
while and you may find that your
prostate it's not as enlarged anymore so
that's a little tip for the prostate
there's other things you can do too now
let's say for example you're going
through menopause okay so and your
estrogen goes down okay
your progesterone goes down even more
giving you a relative ratio of higher
estrogen even though it's low now
there's a little sensor in the bladder
that is supposed to be covered by
estrogen so if you're losing that it
could cause the urge to urinate
frequently okay so if that's the case
the best thing to do is to take
progesterone cream you can take on the
wild yam version and you can rub it into
the thighs and that will help this
situation right here well I think we
covered all the potential reasons for
not sleeping so pick the one that
relates to you and watch the video
thanks for watching if you're liking
this content please subscribe now and I
will actually keep you updated on future
videos